[موسيقى]
رئيس رومانيا السابق والرئيس التركي
الحاليد ابا على تسميه البحر الاسود
بالبحيره الروسيه في ظل عسكرته من قبل
روسيا وهو امر كانت له تداعيات على حلف
الناتو واراضي دولي الاعضاء المطله على
البحر الاسود وسط نشري روسيا اسلحه بعيده
المدى لاسيما في شبه جزيره القرم وهو ما
اضحى يشكل تهديدا مباشره
في رابع عسكري ولم يقدم الناتو على زياده
تسلحه بسبب عسكره روسيا للبحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
اما بالنسبه للمجال البحري فاننا لم
نرنيته يتخذوا اي اجراءات من شانها ردع
روسيا عسكريا الامر الوحيد الذي نلاحظه
حاليا وهو لا صلت له بالنيتو وانما يتعلق
ببلد عضو فيه وهو تركيه هو انه خلال
الساعات الاربع والعشرين او ال 48 الماضيه
قام التركيه بكسر الحصار الذي فرضته روسيا
على تسطير الحبوب الى العالم حيث شاهدنا
الكثيره من سفن الشحن تعبر البحر الاسود
بمرافقه عسكريه وهي اول اشاره يبعث بها
ليس ناتو وانما بلد عضو فيه يسعى الى ردع
روسيا عن عسكره البحر الاسود
حيث تعرضت سفن روسيه للهجوم من قبل
اوكرانيا وليس نيته وقد شاهدنا تداعيات
ذلك على البحر الاسود نفسه والعالم كله
كما ان وجودها في بحار العالم عسكريا قد
تراجع استشير تقارير الى عزم روسيا خفض
وجودها العسكري في البحر الابيض المتوسط
بسبب الخسائر التي تكبدتها في البحر
الاسود هل سيتواصلوا هذا التوجه وهل ستكون
اوكرانيا قادره على الحد من عسكره روسيا
للبحر الاسود هذا امر لا يسعني سوى
التخمين بشانه وربما لم يتخذ بعد قرار حول
ذلك
[موسيقى]